- Hey, guys.
MIKE: Hey.
- Are you Jim?
- Yes, I am.
- Hey.
How you doing?
Frank.
- Nice to meet you, Frank.
- Hey.
Mike.
Talked to Danny on the phone?
I did talk to
Danny on the phone?
How's it going?
He said you were trying
to thin some stuff out.
We're starting to sell things
at my mom and dad's house
in order to clear up some space.
My sister and my
dad used to actually
buy and sell antiques
and knickknacks,
and things like that.
They would sell at
peddler's fairs.
But they stopped doing
that a while ago,
and now it's the time
to part with things.
Here's a big question though.
She said you guys have,
like, a scrap yard.
[laughs] Well, yeah.
Some people might--
- A small one.
- --call it that.
Yeah.
JIM: We like to keep
things hidden around here.
MIKE: Oh--
JIM: OK, that's
exactly how that works.
MIKE: --here we go.
Yeah.
FRANK: That was easy.
I told you it was
behind the scenes.
MIKE: See.
My father collected car parts,
Model T's, and the collection
just kind of kept growing.
What you got here,
a Model T chassis?
JIM: That's a 15.
So this is totally
deceiving from the road.
Remember in The Wizard of
Oz, it's all black and white,
and then she lands
after the tornado--
[interposing voices]
MIKE: --and they open it up.
It's color.
Boom, you come
through the gate--
JIM: Yeah.
MIKE: --this is our color, man.
My dad had a
passion for things.
My mother was an
interior designer,
and this was nothing
that she liked at all.
[laughing]
FRANK: This wasn't
too artistic to her?
JIM: The shade--
this was not her.
MIKE: Yeah.
JIM: And so there's a
fence going down the yard.
And one side of
the yard is Mom's
side and then the other side--
FRANK: He got the sheds.
JIM: --was Dad's side where
the sheds and all the stuff
is stored.
If you look around, you might
find a wood lathe in here.
MIKE: I decided to
just dive right in.
[music playing]
Ah.
There's an outboard motor.
I was cracking up
inside just watching it,
because that's really the
only way to get in there,
is to start climbing on
stuff and digging through it.
Frank, you need a sledge?
He's the first person
who's been to the back
of that shed in 15 years.
What are you finding?
MIKE: Ooh.
FRANK: What do you got?
You dent it, you buy it.
Here's a seat.
This is actually-- this
is early motorcycle.
That's not bicycle.
- Is that what that is?
Yeah, just-- you can
tell by the length.
And this one here,
this is motorcycle too.
These are two early
motorcycle seats.
They're pre 1920.
One is just a
frame, the other one
still has the leather on it.
See the heavy frame?
A bicycle seat and a
motorcycle seat are similar,
but they're completely
different sizes when you're
looking at the early stuff.
A motorcycle seat is
going to be wider.
It's going to be longer, and the
undercarriage of the motorcycle
seat is more heavy duty.
It's built to be sturdier.
This would be
something that would
be cool, like on a
sweaty bike, you know?
Something you don't
want to restore.
Sure.
How about these
two right here?
Would you sell those two?
JIM: Absolutely.
MIKE: How about 75?
[music playing]
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll--
MIKE: Do that?
- --do that.
Absolutely.
- Yeah, this one here--
I mean, you could
spend the money,
but it'd just be a
great parts piece.
MIKE: This is encouraging
to find something
like this in these sheds.
That shows me his father
isn't just buying car parts.